I started the show saying when is
football back that college is a pro well
here's somebody's straddling this lawn
here's somebody who's got a foot in both
college and pro because he also does
Sunday countdown on on on ESPN against
me this how much I like this guy I love
this guy
I just upgraded from liked to love cuz I
just want to be honest he's very
handsome I understand that you actually
passed yourself off as one of his
brothers to poor sage Steele one night
in a post ESPYs party that's fact
exactly and I think I'm done setting up
the introduction a man who had me at
hello
when we first fired up Seahawks came for
him and year six of his 18-year
professional football playing career
he's Matthew Hasselbeck I do in Matthew
hey guys was that appropriate I thought
that was it was all good except for like
on sunday NFL countdown that like
against you like we're not against
football you flip back to the fourth
when I watch football
you know it's a commercial I'm going to
the next channel I'm watching more
football more pregame so it's all
football all the time well all the time
Matthew let's just say when you were
going up against let's just say let's
just throw it out there Ben
Roethlisberger say any any any big game
let's just throw it out here okay are
you going against Ben I mean don't you
think you were going against Ben would
let me be proper terminology yeah I
never thought of it that way but when a
quarterback plays another great
quarterback you know you're just you're
really just going to just try to do the
best that you can do right you know I
could remember even when I you know
Brett Favre was a teammate of mine in
Green Bay for three years and then we
got the chance to play against Brett
Favre a bunch of times and I would just
try to do the best that I could be a
quarterback and then I usually wouldn't
sit on the bench I would stand on the
sidelines and watch him and just
sometimes you just got to tip your cap
when somebody else is doing a great job
too so you know and I think maybe that's
just because at ESPN we don't have any
of those Sunday games like we don't you
know you get it we're just sort of
promoting all the games we don't care
just on CBS NBC ABC we don't care just
you know Fox we're just
talking football so are you saying ESPN
isn't all about ESPN man hey listen they
might be they care about ratings I care
about spirals and touchdowns and endzone
celebrations and that's what I care but
I do like so in all seriousness I mean
what are you're gonna be on a plane like
a million miles this fall right how does
your week work what are you gonna do I'm
all-in
you have no idea I'm actually teaching a
class at Boston College a night yeah so
and then this Thursday Night Football
thing just kind of came together you
know it's been kind of a rotating crew
and I was really like standing on the
table like you guys Thursday Night
Football is like the best look we need
to make Thursday Night Football a thing
and they were like okay you can do it oh
no no no not me like someone else and
they were like no you got it like you
know who do you want to work with and so
anyway I'm working with Pat MacCabe no
Adam Amin Molly McGrath love our team
were diving into college football we got
Luke pickle and chincinatti they won 11
games last year he's coach of the year
and his conference going up against Chip
Kelly mr. innovation trendsetter
brilliant mind a guy I worked with at
ESPN when he was out of football right
so I'm fired up this is like super fun
Cincinnati Ohio is uh is jumping there's
a cult Bengals game here tonight at 7
o'clock and there's a UCLA Bearcats game
here at 7 o'clock in this same city so
it'll be a it will find out you know
like who is it college football's it NFL
football my feeling is that Nippert
stadium just be rocking I think so I
mean if you're going against a fourth
preseason game you know usually what
happens in fourth preseason games and I
do want to talk about the Colts with you
in a second but you know how I feel
about Pat I mean this is gonna be great
the Matt and Pat show or if you don't
mind I'm getting the top billing here
I'm very excited to see what this is
going to be what what is it going to be
do you think we showed up yesterday for
our production meetings with the UCLA
football coaching staff yes we show up
walking like upper deck of the stadium
and on the field we see the
strength and conditioning coaches going
through like a CrossFit workout on the
field with like a hex bar deadlift
pushing a sled and they see us walking
they're like pat down jump in the
workout and well it's sort of just like
laughing hahaha we're not dressed for
that spats in jeans don't wash these in
don't wash jeans with like holes cut out
in the knees next thing I know I look
down pat is on the field pushing a sweat
with 225 pounds he's carrying a hex bar
deadlift doing this CrossFit workout
with the guys before he's running back
up the stairs I think it's gonna be epic
television I think it's gonna be a ton
of fun I said to Adam Amin our
play-by-play guy I'm like listen Adam
you've called everything you've called
the hot dog eating contest got it all
this is gonna be like nothing you've
seen before he said I can't wait man I
can't wait so no wonder he was able to
put down 35 ounces of steak last night
that happened right what happened you
know that's what it is you know I used
to go out for old line dinners the night
before game and we whenever we would
come and play the Bengals there's a
couple restaurants we would hit here in
Cincinnati and the the old linemen would
like trying to finish the big ribeye the
big steak and Pat was up for it last
night and you know just one more thing I
said I know this about you no television
it's no different than playing in the
NFL it's all about the team it's all
about the group there's some people that
are on camera that you know about their
important part of the team there's just
as many people behind the scenes that
you'll never see on camera that matter a
lot and so that's the part that I've
loved so much about this getting to
still be in football talking about pro
football college football and and now
teammates again with Pat McAfee he's
gonna be great Matthew Hasselbeck here
on the Rich Eisen show getting set to
call with McAfee and the crew UCLA at
Cincinnati right here it's tonight on
ESPN and he's right here on the Rich
Eisen show right here let's get to a
former teammate in Andrew Luck with you
Matthew where you just floored stunned
what were you when the news
or did you know beforehand from me I did
not I do not know actually I was texting
with him that day he didn't say anything
to me no probably because of you know my
close relationship with guys like Adam
chapter but it was Adam Schefter that
broke the news right I was watching the
the Miami Florida College football game
and I saw the tweet from Adam Schefter
and I had to read it three times I
thought oh that somehow you know someone
must have hacked Adam chapters Twitter
account like that can't be true
so I texted Adam Schefter and I said hey
the tweet that you just sent out is that
true and he wrote back a hundred like a
hundred percent true and I just I really
didn't believe it quite honestly and
then shortly thereafter it was Adam Amin
on the call for the Chicago Bears
actually where the news was out there
and Adam sorry an Andrew Luck is stuck
on the sidelines there was this really
surreal situation where you had Adam
Amin and Jim Miller talking about it on
television you have Indianapolis Colts
fans taking off their andrew luck
jerseys they can't believe it not how
they expected a third preseason game to
go and Andrew Luck stuck on the
sidelines and so a couple minutes later
Andrew Luck was on camera at a press
conference sharing his side of the story
and it made perfect sense to me like
when I heard it come from him it made it
made perfect sense to me and I don't
think people really realize fully
realize how difficult it is to come back
from one surgery never mind you know
multiple surgeries or multiple injuries
and in the things that football players
have to go through and so it's just it's
unfortunate if you're a fan of football
but knowing Andrew as I do I know that
he's given it a lot of thought and and I
know he's at peace of his decision have
you spoken or texted or communicated
with him at all since then yeah so we
talked on the phone maybe the last two
days and he a hundred percent believes
that he is done with football I think
the hardest part for him is that you
know he's the guy that cares a great
deal about what his teammates think you
know you know he's are in their respect
and he just I think he wanted to make
sure
that his teammates weren't going to
resent him or feel Nate or negatively
towards him but he talked to a lot of
those teammates you know I think you
know even before it broke and you know
those guys were very positive
you know thanking him for what he's
meant in their career thanking him for
the kind of teammate that he was and and
quite remarkably in my mind keeping the
secret like for the amount of teammates
that he talked to for them to keep the
secret is is a testament to the
relationships that he's forged in his
locker room and the respect that guys
have for him and I mentioned it you know
to my wife I said you know it's it's not
only the guys in the locker room that he
shares the teammates that respect him
he's one of those guys that every
opponent every coach that goes a GUP
goes up against him really has a
tremendous amount of respect for him and
that's that's not always the case
you know sometimes you don't respect
guys that you play against you feel like
they're overrated or things like that
but I don't think I don't think anyone
would say that about Angela
Matthew Hasselbeck here in the Rich
Eisen show and the thing that I ate
struck me is just the profound sadness
that he had to that he just came to the
conclusion which in his mind is just
unwavering the conclusion that the only
way out of the way he was feeling forget
about feeling physically feeling
mentally the only way out was to get out
of football and how difficult that must
have been can you for France were still
to this day confused as to how that
could happen can you give voice to
having spoken to him and having played
the position as you did for 18 years
professionally how does that happen well
I think there actually are a lot of guys
that walk away like that
maybe not caliber the hall-of-fame
caliber of an Andrew Luck so we don't
hear about them in the news they don't
show up on the ticker but uh you know
like I said you know a lot of a lot of
things go into it you know sometimes
it's you know you have your identity is
sort of wrapped up and who you are
as a football player what the score on
the scoreboard is what the stats are on
the sheet and sometimes that can get
taken away from you whether it's injury
or whatever and you feel a little lost
you feel isolated from the team you know
especially guys that go on IR they feel
isolated from the team they feel like
they're not plugged in and you know you
met like I think of Rob Gronkowski Rob
Gronkowski had an announcement in New
York City
and we all think of Rob Gronkowski is
like a really fun energetic kind of guy
and he mentioned the fact that hey
physically I could play but mentally and
emotionally and he got choked up and
I've been there like I've been there at
the end of 2015 was the year that I
retired and I knew that the injuries
that I had weren't like serious enough
that I couldn't come back from him but
mentally it wasn't in a place where I
could commit a hundred percent to my
teammates and being all the way back and
I think my feeling is that Andrew Luck
is somewhere in there and where he feels
like you know what I don't know if I
have a hundred percent to give to
everybody and he's not the kind of guy
that would ever be able to look himself
in the mirror if he was giving 85% or
90% he's a guy that would have to give a
hundred percent I played with a guy
named Walter Jones in Seattle one of the
greatest football players of all time
quiet guy offensive lineman maybe people
don't know a lot about him but he
retired because he wasn't able to play
at the standard that he had set for
himself which was one of the great
players of all time at that position and
it was a head-scratcher to a lot of
people but if you knew Walter Jones it
wasn't a head scratcher and I think in
the same way if you go Andrew Luck he's
got to be all-in and whatever he was
dealing with with his latest injury with
a lot of pain you know if he was told
hey listen you could do this but you
might be able to practice once a week or
twice a week I don't think that's the
solution for him that works yeah I know
and it's important that Gronk said what
he said Matt because you know Gronk's
not
known as an over-thinker likes a luck is
and I don't want to for this to come out
of it saying that NFL fans and were NFL
scouts just say stay away from the overt
the the over thinkers and smart guys as
opposed to let's pay attention more to
the mental aspect of this game and help
him help everybody out whether it is you
know some form of a CBD to help with
rehab or to help mentally if it is
marijuana I'm serious like we need to
start thinking about the mental aspect
of this game and look at Lux retirement
that way and Gronk statement that way as
opposed to penalizing the so-called
smart guys yeah I think the biggest
thing that happens is like you know
there's an old-school culture in
football where like if a guy is hurt and
not practicing like the coach won't even
acknowledge your existence like they'll
walk right by you and not say hi to you
because you you're not practicing that
day like there's some of that and we've
gotten better in the football
communities that way but there is a
feeling of isolation when you get away
from the team like when you're not
plugged into the team and I thought to
me the most telling part of the Andrew
Luck press conference was when he was
open and honest and vulnerable about
what his feelings were towards jacobi
percent one of his good friends he said
you know like I was very very jealous of
Jacoby burr said the guy who was you
know the fun-loving you know teammate in
starting quarterback of the Indianapolis
Colts when I wasn't able to be and I
didn't like you know the person that I
was feeling that way and there's just a
lot to that you know like not feeling
part of the team and and I don't know I
just I guess I'm I guess I'm agreeing
with you but also saying that there's
such a mental component to being an NFL
football player where you have to almost
you got to be all-in just like you have
to be physically last one for you on
this one on because I know you got to go
you've played there obviously in
Indianapolis teammates of Andrews what
do you think of the booing and and the
fan reaction
the word I would use is regrettable I
think everyone there will regret it I
kind of understand how it happened they
probably felt like the rug got pulled
out from under them there was a lot of
optimism last year he's a comeback
player of the year they're a team with
Super Bowl aspirations they're feeling
like sometimes people feel like I think
because you make a lot of money and
Andrew Luck makes a lot of money because
you make a lot of money you don't have
any problem like well what problems
could you have you make a lot of money
and you know I think there's some
there's a lack of sympathy for people
who have a high salary and that I
probably would put him into that boat
but uh but I know him personally as
someone that would play for no money he
would play for free and he I have always
felt that way about him and knowing that
I know that like the decision was never
about that the decision was something
else and so for the fans I don't think
they felt that and I think it was sort
of just a knee-jerk reaction I know that
community I played there for three years
there they're a wonderful fanbase but uh
but it was about it was a very bad look
and again I think I would imagine that
in time everyone who did that would
regret it so what do you think having
spoken to Andrew and knowing the
organization knowing the fans yesterday
was on good morning football and the
show I threw it out there that maybe
some point during the season if Andrews
feeling up for it and that the team is
in a position where maybe they're
successful enough that they could
welcome Andrew back for a day maybe he
he comes back for one day and a
half-time ceremony doesn't have to be a
number retirement or doesn't have to be
a ring of Honor but he is just waves to
the crowd and walks through that tunnel
one more time and gives everybody gets a
mulligan what do you think and I love it
and I think the majority of the people I
don't think the fans that were there in
the fourth quarter of the third
preseason game are addicted indicative
of the people that have been there
through and through with the Peyton
Manning and Marvin Harrison and Reggie
Wayne and Dwight Dwight Freeney and
Robert Mathis I mean that is a wonderful
fan base as an opponent going in there I
know what
kind of fans those you know are there in
Indian having been there as a player I
like the idea but I would also say what
I said to Andrew Luck like you know
almost all of us have been there as a
starting quarterback in the NFL where
your home fans get upset with you and
turn on you for a time and it's okay
like it doesn't mean you're a terrible
human it just it's part of the job and
it's an unfortunate part but it's part
of the job and it's not going to be the
worst thing that you ever deal with in
your life well sir you're a great human
as well your whole damn family is it you
know how I feel about the Hasselbeck's
say hi to your whole family I'm so
excited for you for to hear what you and
Pat and the rest of the crew sound like
in the booth and if you if you want me
to Skype in or whatever to one of your
Tuesday night classes I'd love to be I'd
love to yeah I love it now we're now
we're talking I appreciate it I
appreciate it yeah we weave me into the
syllabus Matthew go for it okay well I
had to get my syllabus approved by the
Dean that was the hardest airing I did
this offseason yeah that's a lot of work
man
that is a lot of work all right well you
know next time I want to hear more about
the syllabus you take care of yourself
have a great guy have a great class
tonight
thanks guys neither man that's hassle at
Hasselbeck on Twitter and Instagram for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under rec TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app